I think honestly,
an antiquated form of government
that could make a comeback is direct democracy,
or at least elements of it.
with smartphones,
with the internet,
we kind of do have the technology
that we can at least start to envision ways
that we would have public decision making,
truly public decision making,
non representative
but direct instead,
right in fact,
I think you're seeing elements of it already.
more and more states,
the United States,
more and more countries
put important political ideas to referendum
and citizen led initiatives.
you know, we didn't have those to any significant extent.
50 years ago,
maybe even 30 years ago.
I don't know the history of that exactly,
but we didn't have those.
so not only could it come back,
I think we're seeing it make those first small
incremental steps to come back.